hello I'm Greg Sadler and I would like
to invite you if you're interested to
join me on a new course which will be
meeting monthly for lectures and
discussions called understanding anger
now I did a sequence like that back in
2015 you may have seen some of the
videos from that series with the
Kingston Library hosting having live
discussions which I video recorded and
put into my channel and I've been doing
work on anger understood from
philosophical literary and other
perspectives for a very long time before
that and after that and I've been
teaching classes at Marquette University
that are focused primarily on that
problem of understanding anger using a
variety of sources from ancient medieval
modern even late modern philosophy
psychology literature Theology and other
things and so people started asking me
hey is there any chance that you would
start that lecture series back up again
and I I gave it some thought and I said
yeah actually that would be great a lot
of fun uh it would be much more
open-ended who knows how long we could
go with it there's enough material there
to go for years and years and we could
look at texts that I never got to in the
original series or we could do deeper
Dives so that's exactly what we're going
to be doing starting in February 2023
where we'll have our very first
inaugural session where I'll talk about
anger in general and different
approaches to it and you know throw a
few interesting quotes from ancient
philosophy and literature out there for
people to chew on and then we'll discuss
how the entire course is going to go
we're going to start meeting monthly
from that point on generally on the
third Saturdays of a month noon Central
and we will be meeting using Zoom you'll
access that by enrolling in the course
for free in my study with Sadler Academy
then you get the zoom link and then you
can show up and ask questions make
comments get answers about whatever it
is that you're interested in for each of
the sessions all present for a little
while although you know my lectures can
be very interactive and then I'll ask
some questions we'll have some broader
discussion and I'll be clueing people
into what sources they might take a look
at you know for the text it's going to
be a structured curriculum it's of
course not for credit just personal
enrichment once you're enrolled every
month you'll get updates about you know
what to expect what we're going to be
discussing and you know how you can
prepare for the sessions we'll be
recording the sessions which then later
will go into my YouTube channel for the
general public and we'll do a video
premiere allowing additional uh live
chat between me and the people who are
watching it some of whom may be enrolled
in the course as well so they get the
double whammy right so this is going to
be quite exciting it's uh an area that
I've been researching really now for
over two decades I've done a lot of
publishing about it and a lot of
presentations but you know I really did
like going through things one month at a
time with you know some some reading
suggested ahead of time and this first
year we're going to be looking primarily
at Greek philosophy and Greek literature
so we're going to start with that
initial session and then we'll go into
some Play-Doh stuff where does anger
show up in the platonic dialogues what
does Plato have to say about it as it
turns out there's a lot more than people
might expect and then we're going to
look at some Greek literature some
poetry namely you know Homer and Hessian
and some of the great tragedies and then
we'll come back and you know spend some
time with Aristotle the first theorist
who really defines anger examines it
from a number of different perspectives
we're actually going to spend two whole
months on Aristotle stuff and we may
come back to him later on in the future
then we're going to look at what you
know epicurus and lucretius have to say
and we'll start moving into some of the
other thinkers and that'll that'll cover
the rest of this year so if you're
looking for something saying free
engaging well researched and interactive
you might very well want to sign up for
this so you might be saying well how do
I do that well you know in the video
description below you are going to see a
link for the class itself you go into
teachable if you have a teachable
account it's like just a couple clicks
to sign up for this class if you don't
have a teachable account then you will
have to create one but that's easy to do
and then you're signed up for the class
you're in the community and you'll start
getting the updates every so often about
what we're going to be doing in the
class so I've already got nine or ten
people signed up for it at this point in
time I'm hoping that you can join me for
it you can also click the video
description and you'll see what the
sessions coming up are going to be
covering discussing delving into so I
think this will be very useful for
people it's uh it is focused on
understanding anger but it can also be
applied to your own life your
relationships you know your personal
development your career uh are very
anger-filled uh political sphere in the
present and we might even say culture in
general and hopefully uh studying these
things will prove as exciting and
interesting and compelling for you as it
has for me sustaining me in a as I
pointed out more than two decades of
researching and writing on And
discussing and thinking about and
applying these things so that's enough
for me to talk about right now I hope
that you'll consider joining me for this
there's no commitment that you're making
you can participate in as many or as few
of the sessions as you like you could be
alert worker if you want to you can be
very actively engaged but it is
something that I'm going to be offering
and so I would throw it I thought I
would throw it out there for anybody who
wants to get involved to have that
opportunity so looking forward to the
first session and I'll see some of you
there